hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess congress and this game
ate Louie Paulson versus Paul Charles
Murphy's so more fees leading it's
morphin won four games one game was lost
well for Murphy and two games were drawn
so let's see what happens in game eight
Paulsen opened with e4 and more feet
once again or replies with ePHI with
Knight f3 Knight to c6 and Knight to c3
now inviting the four night we have
Knight to f6
the four Knights game is on the board
and now d4 by by Paulsen with Bishop to
b4 by morphine developing and pinning
the knight and Bishop to b5 now so
pretty symmetrical symmetrical opening
night captures on e4 by Murphy and now
Queen to d3
defending the c3 Knight twice and it's a
temporary point sacrifice but Murphy now
just replies with d5 he strengthens his
knight on e4 and keeps the tension on
the board Paulsen grabs his pawn back
with Knight captures on e5 and here we
have castles by Murphy and it is as a
remove seven that disposition was never
reached again and here Paulsen also
castles it's a very important to the
castle early and often as the quote
above the board says here a lot of
things could go wrong for example if you
don't cast line you play something like
a three you want to clear up the
situation in front of your King do you
see how black takes advantage of this
it's quite a nifty idea so feel free to
pause the video and figure out how to do
this well I give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that well
III don't even know how to phrase this
but congratulations to everyone who did
it and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's either Bishop captures on c3 or
just Knight characters on e5 right away
the move and move order doesn't really
matter point is that after Knight
captures any five characters you're
gonna capture on c3 be be pond has to
capture as the knight guards the c3
square and now you play c6 and now after
Bishop to a4 which is you only move if
you don't want to lose lose a piece
better pay for
now you plain Knight captures on f2 and
after Lysa King characters Queen to h4
check King has to move and now you just
pick up the bishop here and well white
position is completely busted and you
will have an awesome game here so like I
said a lot of things can go wrong
I so posting just castles and now Morphy
goes for the for the exact same set of
Knight captures an e5 we have D captures
it special captures and c3b captures and
now c6 Bishop a4 and okay now you don't
have the the Knight captures an f2 but
that's F 2 but still it's a it's a very
promising position for Morphy and the
Queen here with the idea of just
grabbing here and maybe picking up the
bishop but then just Bishop b3 doesn't
really do all that much for black but it
is playable morphe decides to go as this
is a very important game if he wins it
he wins the first American chess
congress he goes for Queen to a5 instead
he creates a double attack here a double
attack on the c3 pawn while attacking
the bishop on a4 so Russia back to b3 in
now just Queen captures on c3 Morphy
will gladly trade Queens here as he's up
a pawn he has to balance the poisons
three porn islands and he he feels very
confident that he can win this we have
Bush up to f4 by Paulson now defending
the e5 pawn and Bishop the f5 by
morphine continuing development also the
if the knight moves there could be some
some some tricks so as the queen is on
this diagonal and now look the c1 by
Paulsen it's not easy to actually find a
move here Trading Queens will never be
good for you for example if Queen
captures on c3 you're just gonna reach
capture and now after you have to move
the bishop 90 to check is the thread
that will just eliminate there so after
the bishop moves 90 to check your king
is gonna move and now let's say rook FD
8 and the black has an excellent game
not much to do here with white it why
does have the bishop pair although this
Bishop is is basically a pawn for the
moment so not not much to be done about
that so after Bishop to a5 dimorphic
rook a to c1 probably to help out with
the defense of the c2 upon at some point
it might become an issue however more
fish
this is not a great place for the rook
by playing g5 and g5 is is a really nice
idea
it says okay you either March your
Russia back and then then I just grab
more space
your Bishop will no longer be
controlling the five points so I can
eliminate the pawn and Paulsen is
reluctant to give you yet another pawn -
Morphy and the problem is it does seem
like you can capture the Queen and after
Knight captures captures back then the
g5 pawn is no longer defended however
after wasn't played this Queen captures
in c3 Knight characters and Bishop
captures in g5 no Murphy just has night
Stewie to check forking the king and the
rook so by avoiding the loss of yet
another pawn Paulsen agrees to give up
the exchange so King h1 Morphy grabs the
rook Knight captures and c1 bishop
recaptures sorry a rook recaptures not
and not Bishop after Knight character so
rookery captures the knight and here we
have rook ft8
now putting pressure on the pawn here
Bishop to f6 defending and it's not the
end of the world a person still has the
bishop pair however as long as this
bishop is a pawn that's that's not the
way to use your bishop pair and now b5
by morphine he's preparing to go a 5 and
a 4 to trapdoor at the LightSquared
Bishop with f3 Morphy continues with a 5
and now a 3 of course you don't want
your Bishop trapped Bishop back to e6
now creating a very nifty idea looked at
b1 now preventing c5 because you will
lose the d5 pawn but now b4 by morphe
and now it's not not at all clear if you
push the a4 pawn at some point you can
just start pushing the C point so the
position will not remain closed more if
you will get his open files for the rook
bishop the a4 seems like maybe a decent
try but again after rook to see it
doesn't doesn't leave white with much
so instead Paulsen just captured on
before with a character son b4 and now a
ch3 just trying to improve the position
a little bit but now more he finds a
brilliant idea morphe plays c5 here and
it's the same in every game Paulsen
really takes a lot of time for his moves
and the more fear very rarely take
more than five minutes most of the moves
he played where we were played in under
a minute
and here it's it's wonderful that he's
giving up the d5 pawn but actually
taking the the d5 pawn is super
complicated because after Bishop
captures on d5 you get rook a to d8 you
offer a rook this is just incredible
stuff and now you either capture it or
you try c4 to defend your Bishop doesn't
really matter let's say capture some
pass on you're gonna give up the rook
and after before look at ROS you're
gonna play C to attack the rook move the
rook back and only now capture on d8 and
now the problem is white doesn't have
time for captures because rook to d1
check wins the game so what would what
white would have to do is just say okay
I don't have time for that I have to
eliminate the past pawn and then you
just pick up the bishop you're up a
piece and of course in a completely
winning game so a really problematic
move for pulse and this c5 idea by
morphe proposing try c3 not not much to
go on but morphe characters and B
characters in c3 he doubles his pawns
but now it's a it's a strong past C pawn
with Bishop the c2 pulse and blocks it
but now just look to a to buy more fee
with rook the c1 and now rook rook eta a
doubling up here preparing rook to a1
Bishop to g5 now keeping an eye on the
rook here but still rook to e1 not much
to be done here
Bishop to be one blocking and now of
course you all see more of his next move
without even pausing the video as its
well it's it's it's just out there
so congratulations everyone for seeing
it it's of course c2 and it was in this
position unmoved 29 that Lois Paulsen
resigned the game and yet another
victory for Paul Charles Murphy in the
first American chess congress in the
finals here he resigns because if you
capture it with the rook you just lose
the piece rook captures here and if you
don't if you capture it with the bishop
then it's just rook captures Bishop
characters and rooked a one now again
winning the material king gage - you're
just gonna capture here and once the
bishop moves again we end up in a young
gustafson end game where one player is
upper rook so really impressive
impressive play by morphine in the end
it was quite a quite a struggle now if
it wasn't for that game - that that game
- that really put morphine depression
mode I think that the result would be
much higher in Murphy's favor here the
result ends in six - - in Murphy's favor
as five games were won by Murphy two
games were drawn and one game was won by
by paulsen but you know it's it's hard
to say but that game to really really
put a number on Murphy and he he really
had needed to two games to get to get
out of it so what happens now is that of
course they are the first American chess
congress has finished they are presented
with their prizes and since Murphy
refused to accept money for chess he
never accepted money for any chess any
prize that he won even if you had put up
some prizes to attract another chess
player for a match he would still
decline it even if the other player got
money so here all the other participants
got their money first place was won by
more fees second place of course by
Paulson third place lifting hein and
fourth place by Raphael and everyone got
money prizes except Murphy he received a
silver silver plate in the indie amount
of $300 that was the first prize and
although $300 maze may not seem like a
lot of money in 1857 I've used an online
Inflation Calculator to crunch the
numbers what would $300 in 1857 be worth
the day it's about $9,000
so basically of purchasing power so
basically that's that's that's that's
how fancy that silver plate was and also
I would just like to I would just like
to read to you some what was what was
engraved on that silver plate so it says
this service of plate is presented to
Paul Morphy the victor in the Grand
Tournament at the first Congress of the
American National Chess Association new
york 1857 so that that was presented to
him and also it's i would like to
mention that stein it's in 1885 spoke of
murphy and this competition in his in
the international chess magazine
time it said that the the this whole
idea of morphe being unbeatable was was
a bit overhyped and he used exactly game
to her morphe switch the move order
where he grabbed at the queen and
delivered check on g6 before actually
capturing the night to present that even
more if he can make a mistake but what
he didn't know while making that while
writing that was that morphe really made
that move instantly whereas Paulson
thought for some 35 minutes before
morphe made his well so-called blunder
the game was drawn in the end but still
that was tiny fused and it is known that
shines II did not know this detail that
that morphe pretty much played his moves
instantly but when it came to praising
morphe stein it's also praised murphy
for example regarding game 6 the
legendary game 6 against paulsen stein
it said that it was it was really a
masterpiece he put it on the front page
of the of the chess instructor the
modern chess instructor and it said that
it was printed in gold so that's how
that's how much he praised morphe for
that one so really a lot of interesting
stuff and also i would just like to read
one small part from David Lawson's book
and Paul Morphy
regarding McDonald's well McNutt
McDonald's view of morphine in his book
chest life pictures so here it said he
described Murphy and his manner of
playing having witnessed many of his
games when in England his smile was
delightful it seemed to kindle up the
brain fuel that that fed his eyes with
light and it made them shoot more fourth
most brilliant rays he moved very fast
but never hurriedly he never put his
hand near a piece until he was going to
move it nor placed any of them in
exactly on the board so as to leave his
antagonist doubtful as to its position
never swooped down upon a piece he was
going to capture nor described an
atmospheric arc with his arm previous to
making the coop that was to strike the
spectators with wonder or ensure for him
the victory Morphy generally kept his
eyes fixed instantly upon the board
while while he was playing yet like the
gentleman he
we buckle he always looked up from it as
soon as he had a winning game but never
with an exulting or triumphant gaze he
seldom in fact in my presence never
expended more than a minute or two over
his best and deepest combinations he
never seemed to exert himself much less
the Kajal Kajal his brains but played
with consummate ease as though his moves
were the result of inspiration I fancy
he always discerned the right move at a
glance and only paused before making it
partly out of respect for his antagonist
and partly to certify himself of its
correctness to make assurance doubly
sure and to accustom himself to sobriety
of demeanor in all circumstances I fully
agree with mr. Borden's opinion that he
possessed a truly gigantic capacity for
chess that was never fully called forth
because even its partial development
sufficed to enable him to triumph over
all opponents that that's what McDonald
said so now some some people often say
that morphia he's an interesting guy but
he wasn't all that strong I mean his
opponents were weren't all that
impressive but that's that's that's what
it is Magnus Crossan is where he is
because his opponents require that of
him if he wants to beat them he has to
be that good more if he had to be this
good to beat him to win the first
American chess congress and that's why
he was that good so that that's
something to also put in perspective so
yeah what happens next
morphe is now the winner of the first
American chess congress and mr. Willard
Fisk receives a letter from Howard
Stanton of England where he says that he
was following all the games he enjoyed
all the games and that he he thinks that
in the future maybe a contest could be
organized between Morphy and himself and
the Morphy and Fisk started well started
discussing about this whole idea of
maybe traveling to England and maybe
traveling to Europe visiting some other
countries because okay the players in
the first American chess congress were
strong but they're not act exactly
strong as the players in Europe the
European chess chess masters were much
which were much stronger and much more
famous
so this is where we will stop this video
as in the next video we are going to
continue morphe is travelling to Europe
and the wooja we'll just take it from
there so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
we're at we wrapped up the first
American chess congress so now you know
a little bit more how he came there how
they had who he defeated how they had
the awesome chess party you know the
metric ins Paulsen if you've never
really covered it or maybe it went
through the games you know you maybe
thought okay more if you just completely
destroyed Paulson but not really you
know Paulson did have his moments so
just put just putting it out there but
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Manuel Martinez Irish carp
young Jeff graves Cameron Ford and John
Lynch for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
videos here thankful for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the Murphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day